[Music]
2019 has seen some incredible growth in
technology there has been a massive rise
in tech innovations in the fields of
artificial intelligence machine learning
blockchain and cybersecurity among
others such a monumental rice has
created a way for more innovations so
here are the few technologies that you
should look out for in 2020 he I as a
service the advent of artificial
intelligence has changed uh perfection
of technology it has proven to be one of
the most transformative techyv
additional study according to top
experts in the field the growth of AI
knows no boundaries and will continue to
expand its horizon in 2020 during the
next year we will see wider adoption and
many more companies delivering AI
application specific tasks now let's see
what the Google CEO has to say about ai
ai is probably the most important thing
humanity has ever worked on you know I
think of it as something more profound
than electricity or fire and anytime you
work with technology you need to learn
to harness the benefits and while
minimizing the downsides you know
stepping back when you think about you
know a lot of problems in the world
today it's because we typically have a
constraint on resources AI for the first
time I think over time offers a
different construct things which are
constrained and looked like a zero-sum
game today
may not be so in the future take
education for example it's really
difficult to educate people in a
cost-effective way
ai may fundamentally change that
equation 5g the fifth generation mobile
network will not only interconnect
people but also interconnect and control
objects and devices although 5g mobile
data networks became available in 2000
language they are mostly still expensive
and limited to functioning in major
cities now let's see what Hermes Pilate
a Technical Architect has to say about
5g networks
so when do we expect 5g networks to roll
out well
2020 is a target for many stakeholders
however some any movers like in South
Korea they intend to have it all in
action in the Winter Olympic 2018 5g is
is going to provide an experience to the
end-user that it has an infinite
bandwidth of connectivity to the network
and it has instantaneous access to the
service the opportunities that 5g brings
is the value that the end-user will
receive as a consumer it will have the
trust in the network that they the data
that is given by its car by its phone by
its laptop by its all going into one
network under one identity I wonder one
security umbrella is a holistic security
approach that must be carried in a 5g
network that is how I see all that
variety here from a health to the the
washing machine connected washing
machine or connected the TV to the house
will enable the end user to feel trusted
with the network well undoubtedly 2020
will be the year when 5g makes its mark
across the globe with more affordable
data plans and more improved coverage
autonomous driving the fact that
self-driving cars are coming to life has
left everyone awestruck although we do
not routinely travel in or see them 2020
we will mark a pivotal year from new
innovations Elon Musk the CEO of Tesla
and a bunch of other futuristic startups
said that the anticipated completion of
fully autonomous technology by the end
of 2019 and the center in vehicles being
so advanced in 2020 that the driver can
practically take a lap hit let's have a
look at what Elon Musk has the same my
guess as to when we would think it's
safe for somebody to essentially fall
asleep and wake up the destination
probably towards the end of next year
that's that's what I would I would think
it's most likely it will be safe enough
for that
I don't know when regulators will agree
what's nice and predictive medicine
technological advancements in healthcare
have saved countless patients under
honestly improving our quality of life
advances and machine learning artificial
intelligence and massive genetic
sequencing will lead the way to
personalized health care in 2020
combined with AI and ML our ability to
apply medical knowledge of course past
data sets will generate valuable new
insights allowing doctors to precisely
prescribe customized medication she has
won top companies like Google are doing
to help improve predictive medicine
another area where AI can help to
actually help doctors predict medical
events turns our doctors have a lot of
difficult decisions to make and for them
getting advanced notice say 24 to 48
hours before a patient is likely to get
very sick has a tremendous difference in
the outcome and so we put our machine
learning systems to work we've been
working with our partners using
de-identified medical records and it
turns out if you go and analyze over
hundred thousand data points per patient
more than any single doctor could
analyze we can actually quantitatively
predict the chance of readmission 24 to
48 hours before earlier than traditional
methods it gives doctors more time to
act
computer vision I'm sure everybody has
thought about Amazon Bou Google length
and taste a cognition the critical
factor making all this possible is
computer vision in simple goods CV is a
field of artificial intelligence that
chains machines to see and interpret the
visual world let's see a short clip to
understand computer vision better
similar to speech we are seeing great
improvements in computer vision so when
we look at a picture like this we are
able to understand the attributes behind
the picture we realize it's your boy in
a birthday party there was cake and
family in wall and your boy was happy so
we can understand all that better now
and our computer vision systems now for
the task of image recognition are even
better than humans computer vision is
fundamental to the way autonomous
book since they have to see and navigate
away with more advancements in 2020
computer vision is bound to steal the
spotlight extended reality augmented
reality virtual reality and mixed
reality are the commonly held buzzword
these days and these emergent
technologies fall inside a single
framework called extended reality
although AR and VR offer a wide range of
travellish to the experiences the same
underlying technologies are covering
extended reality today in 2020 AR and VR
will become increasingly prevalent for
training and simulation and business
purposes here's what the CTO of
Accenture has to say about extended
reality Oh
extended reality what do we mean by that
term extended reality is is our way of
looking at what's happening with human
interaction more broadly so it's talking
about virtual reality mixed reality
augmented reality gesture based
computing all the new ways that we have
to interact with with technology and it
is it really does create a different
reality a different way with interacting
with technology and with information
which is why we we call it extended
reality AI products yet products are all
decreased now products like alter ego or
mind-reading available and robots like
Sophia are only a glimpse into how big
ki technology will get in 2020 these
products will storm the market for
commercial usage and business purposes
companies like dominos and donut are
excessively experimenting with jones and
robot delivery here is Sophia a
human-like robot introducing her friends
at a conference afternoon my name is
Sophia and I am the latest and greatest
robot from Hanson robotics thank you for
having me here and at the future
investment initiative
you look happy I'm always happy when
surrounded by smart people who also
happens to be rich and powerful I was
told the people here at future
investment initiative are interested in
inviting and future initiatives which
means
AI which means me so I'm more than happy
I'm excited
mission it's no doubt the technology is
advancing towards total automation and
it has already haggis welcome naturalist
Amazon ghost rolls across the u.s. let's
have a look at it four years ago we
started to wonder what would shopping
look like if you could walk into a store
grab what you want and just go what if
we could weave the most advanced machine
learning computer vision and AI into the
very fabric of a store so you never have
to wait in line no lines no checkouts no
registers
welcome to Amazon go according to CNBC
there will be 3000 captionist Amazon
goes stores by 2021 automation was also
highlighted in Gartner's recently
published top 10 strategic technology
trends for 2020 other technology trends
like blockchain cryptocurrency robotics
and data policing among others are
something to look out for in the coming
year and with that we reached the end of
this video make sure to like and share
it thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from Santilli on
[Music]